the highly anticipated movie a star is  born' opens this weekend and I saw I saw  the movie we had Bradley Cooper on the  show I saw the movie it is amazing it's  fantastic Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga  have just amazing chemistry in the film  especially check this out  there's this one scene from the movie  and you can really see their chemistry  at work you'll see them don't giggle  it's not a we haven't been a comedy show  in two years this is now we just  seriously review movies you'll look at  their chemistry you'll see what I'm  talking about  oh I'm gonna blow your nose we're very  sad truth yeah your boys should I touch  your nose oh my gosh ah nice touch it  for a second  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Applause]  you